in nepal's capital kathmandu
hospitals are so overwhelmed they're now
treating patients on the floor
in hallways and even outside
they told me my mother's oxygen level
was low and asked me to find a bed
somewhere else
because the hospital was packed i tried
many places and found one outside this
hospital
only one bed was vacant when we arrived
here we were lucky to get it
there's also a desperate need for oxygen
canisters climbers
on mount everest have been asked to
bring back their empty tanks
so they can be refilled for coronavirus
patients
but the situation on the mountain is
also worrying
with guides describing an outbreak at
base camp although that's been denied by
the government
with all the confirmed cases we know now
confirmed from pilots from
insurances from doctors from expedition
leaders
i have the positive tests so so we can
prove this
we have at least 100 people minimum
positive for covet in base camp much of
the world's attention has been on the
crisis in india
but aid agencies and medical workers are
warning of an unfolding human
catastrophe in neighbouring nepal
its inoculation campaign has almost
ground to a halt
after india banned exports of covert
vaccines
transmission could be less in urban
areas in the coming weeks
but it has reached the villages which is
a cause for concern
we would ask them to check oxygen levels
prescribed medicine and x-rays but it's
not available there
some accused prime minister kp sharma
olli are fuelling the crisis
he's repeated claims that covert is no
worse than the flu
ollie says his government's made every
possible effort to save people
blaming a lack of resources and
infrastructure
but anger over his government's handling
of the outbreak has added to what was
already a political stalemate
the president dissolved parliament on
saturday to make way for elections
the very purpose of the state and
politics is to protect its
people which is a pandemic and now our
attention has been diverted
to to the to the election elections are
important for democracy but i don't know
what kind of election that we are
talking so i think it's a misplaced
priorities
to cover up political incompetencies of
the government
experts predict nepal could see 40 000
deaths by july
a toll worse than any other country in
the region for the size of its
population
funeral pyres and kathmandu burn day and
night
with families forced to grieve at a
distance
and often alone alexia o'brien al
jazeera